Peggy's 16
hello I'm Adam containing I'm the head
of game design at dec13 interactive and
I would like to welcome you to our demo
of the surge with me today a Sebastiana
soy built they'll be doing the driving
today but before we begin I'd like to
give you a quick summary of our game the
surge is a hardcore action RPG with a
focus on tactical melee combat we're in
a dystopian near future version of Earth
you can see here from the surroundings
things are a little broken up in our
game global warming and ecological
problems have advanced to crisis levels
in the world likewise the global economy
is in shambles so regular men and women
are in a lot of trouble it's really
difficult for people to find work so our
hero Warren is lucky to have found a job
at all particularly at a company like
creo which is dedicated to solving the
world's ecological problems so his first
day on the job he's getting his XO rig
applied you can see here attached to his
body and you know some of our other
materials but something goes very wrong
with this process he loses consciousness
and wakes up here so let's get going ok
so this is an operation center functions
a bit like a hub for us you can you can
do some crafting here you can use your
text scrap to level up your XO rig but
we're not going to do that yet we're
going to head right into the action one
of our new coworkers he's not very good
shape as we can see he's a little
aggressive we're going to need to defend
ourselves now melee combat in the surge
is stamina base that means that while
you're in combat and you need to manage
your stamina resource or you might find
yourself unable to complete a combo that
you want to finish or you know unable to
dodge away from a counter-attack it's
just something you need to pay attention
to while you fight and in the surge
attacks are not light or heavy attacks
but rather horizontal and vertical
attacks that's because the swing
direction of your attacks actually
matters in the surge you can see here
you can target specific body parts so
directing attacks towards unarmored or
vulnerable areas deals increased damage
it's more likely to stagger your
opponent so it really pays to observe
your enemies pick out their weak points
when you're when you're going in for the
kill there another thing that we really
like to emphasize that it's really good
and beneficial for you to scan your
environment to look around for enemies
and loot you know exploration is really
important to us so looking around we see
this guy in the dark banging his head
now he's different from the other
enemies we fought so far in that he has
a helmet which is something that maybe
we want to take home with us make it
ours so that brings me to the other
aspect of body part targeting which is
that if you target a body part and deal
enough damage you will then be able to
use combat energy like this to execute
and finishing sequence hmm me so you
chop off that body part you loot it and
then we can take that back to the
operation center where we can use our
new blueprint to craft that helmet for
our very own selves
that's not very nice so moving further
into the area here you can see that we
don't have just humanoid enemies we also
have a variety of robotic enemies many
of these will also have limbs that can
be chopped off you know this could give
you various rewards new implants need
weapons things like that but these
disassembly drones are more simple they
don't have different body parts and just
trying to chop you up we're not going to
let them do that what is this you see
something in the rocket shell over here
okay this is also a new blueprint so
when we return to operations will be
able to craft the security staff as well
looks like we're not able to go through
that door yet but there is an overcharge
station nearby so overcharging allows
you to channel the core power of your XO
rig to overload some circuit sometimes
that will open doors sometimes that will
add power to places I had no power oh
and sometimes it will allow you to be
jumped by a giant robot dog you can see
here the robot dog is a little bit of a
mini boss for the purposes of this demo
it's much more aggressive than the other
enemies we fought field welcome damage
but see it also has a weakness punch it
right in its robot I and it's a leaping
at us and we can actually can erupt it
and then score a follow-up attack of our
own
careful all right now we have him taken
care of we can explore the warehouse a
little bit more well maybe he'll be
friends no I guess not guess he doesn't
want to be friends I think it's really
important to us is that all of our
enemies have purpose in the world see
that these guys they have a heavier rig
they have these forests weapons you know
they really fit in the area that they're
found they're kind of like these mover
loader employees but the way they yell
and attack you shows that there's
something still a bit wrong with them up
here's an XO lift when we try that out
or we will not you will deal with our
friend here and then we will use the
exit live our two friends
alright well done two for one okay so an
EXO lift it's the way that that Warren
can reach different vertical areas can
go higher or lower it functions very
much like a ladder but we think it's
cooler now here's another overcharge
station the difference is that this one
is higher level now like I mentioned
before exploration is a major element of
the game for us and you'll have a lot of
reasons to explore the world of the
search we see our levels as being pretty
Metroidvania in nature they're really
interconnected and you'll find a lot of
areas that you're not able to access
until later in the game until you have
more power different capabilities so
when you find something that you're not
able to open yet it's really a good
reason to backtrack later to fully
explore a lot of times you'll find other
encounters or rare loot but now that
we've turned on the power to the
warehouse here we're able to go through
this door we just open which seems to
open up a shortcut back to the
operations so that's a pretty good
opportunity for us to craft some new
gear with all these blueprints that
we've gathered
this is not a schedule to make a trip
over anytime thank you so up ahead here
is a med bay this is what allows you to
use your texts crap to power up your XO
rig it heals you of course and then here
we have a crafting station so let's use
that ok so we see the blueprints that
we've acquired so far we see the helmet
we see the staff physicians doing staff
anything lower weapons and this is
really the the court here early for the
game you know you cut off pieces from
your enemies you learn the blueprints
and then you use those to craft new
equipment for yourself so let's go ahead
and try on some of these things be
crafting security staff loader weapons
sweet new helmet that we got before and
we also have this armor piece now this
particular piece of chest armor will
illuminate in the darkness and cast
these bright lights it helps you to see
helps me to find enemies and find loot
you know other armors will you know do
things like protect you from
environmental hazards so it's really
important for you to experiment with
different pieces of equipment see what
sort of special effects they give so
that you know how to approach all the
challenges of the world most effective
way so what I said we can use text crap
at the med bay that level of our core
power looks like right now yeah we don't
have enough to get a full level up yet
but that's okay because now we banked
that text crap so we don't lose it when
we die and then we also have the
implants which I mentioned before so
implants can have passive benefits they
can also be active injectables like
sebastiana has been using the recovery
as health when he slowed but all
implants use different amounts of core
pal so as you play the game you really
have to sort of balance the core power
requirements and your total core power
against the you know your personal
gameplay style that sort of effects that
you think are most important
alright so why don't we head out and try
some of these new new toys that we've
made be careful out there okay so this
is the way we like to do cutscenes in
search don't like to take control the
camera make the cut seems all part of
them
that means is that
wash them or not they're always going to
pay attention and hobbies it's really a
fee sometimes we'll offer context camera
so you can have a more cinematic view
but it's never required it's always your
choice and all of our different weapons
they have different movesets different
fields altogether different finishing
sequences from brutal so as you get new
weapons in the surge you'll really want
to test them out see which one feels the
best you which one is most effective in
your own hands surely your choice see
the loader weapons will go faster more
agile or more combo but also pretty
brutal ok so now that we're more
comfortable with these these new weapons
why don't we go back through the
shortcut and see what's on the other
side of things
the dangerous reading in progress okay
yeah so I was talking before about the
context camera this is what lets you
have a more cinematic view as this angry
boss robot gets up out of the rubble
primary way you can watch it if you want
you could also prepare for the boss
divest you can see he wanted to shoot
you with the railgun fortunately for him
it is malfunction so he's going to have
to use a little bit more of a personal
touch
that we're not actually doing damage to
the boss's real health so we are
increasing the threat analysis meter so
unless you should figure out what
happens when the threat analysis is full
punitive measures not rehabilitation
implemented well of course rockets
Congrats
that's what I do but we still haven't
dealt any damage to its real health bar
so maybe if we're careful those rockets
against it
rehabilitation
okay there we go so now he forced it to
be hit by its own rockets we're able to
target its armor piece knock it off and
then give it a good solid plunge right
in robot brain which has dealt some real
damage let's see if we can repeat this
process one thing to note is that you
know this is this is one way to defeat
the boss but it's certainly not the only
way to defeat the boss and this easier
method does not allow you to receive a
more powerful does we want the best
things top the bosses then North African
scary encounter
shillong not really it's not anything
about honor
shreddin house is almost full again
measures dispensing sentence
okay very nice boss to feed it well done
so that's the search scheduled for
release in 2017 on next-gen consoles and
PC once again I'm Adam hit a knee for
dec13 interactive thanks for watching